il ya la roue la roue des chroniques
meuf
je vous le dis elle va dire il y a
quatre il ya trois joker je vais tourner
la roue on va jouer avec harry et par
moi même fils est un des chroniqueurs on
va jouer attrape moi si tu peux
il y a des trappes avec des des choses
un petit peu bizarre dedans à chaque
fois on va lancer le dé et les jours
celui qui aura le plus petit nombre
devra s'allonger et on nous verra une
trappe
je peux vous dire que c'est des moments
exceptionnels tout le monde y est quoi
c'est pas à ce que vous voulez que je
tourne la roue désignera larves et en
importe qu'elle ait bien joseph gardien
je devais de venir tourner la roue parce
qu'il faut qu'on la balle et on va aller
vite a dit la patronne loupe pas trop le
vol aller ou pas il va bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
john kerr très bien les chéris joker je
choisis donc la personne qui va venir
nous rejoindre
il y aura un habitant il y aura moi même
il y à des insectes de fou rexie je vous
dirai dans un instant qui j'ai choisi à
tout on est tombé sur le dos caire c'est
le public qui va choisir qui voulez-vous
ont joué avec nous en 3ème pas attention
le d c'est très simple je vous dis cette
séquence est folle à chaque foyer une
pression est donc aux dames en
maturation
alors tu prends quelqu'un tu t'es dit je
vais me de prudence quoi on arrive on
arrive tu prends qu'elle des choix je
vais prendre le rouge tient le ballon
mathieu le bleu fait un bleu et ben je
vais prendre le jaune merci jurement un
truc quoi pas de serpents n'y a pas de
serpent que tu veux mais tu prends tu
peux toujours bien le jure qu'à partir
et le jure je ne retiendra pas la
violence et je le jure je ne retiendrai
pas la violence sinon sur qui sur toi tu
achètes sur moi sur mon cher et précieux
je te le jure ok ça va me faire
confiance à allez vas-y tu débat
attention le plus beau site c'est ça
sort c'est moi qui commence deux des
trois quarts plus maintenant gfr
deux autres jeunes allaient dans ce sens
nous deux c'est un oui mais je suis
pourtant déjà fait partir des vols
puisque j'étais sûre d'avoir perdu à
nice tu viens t'en ont lieu dans
l'ensemble à l'espace 1 2 3 à 0
question les peler question les pieds le
premier c'est sympa ce sont les pieds ce
sont des chansons
la jolie pippa attention tu es parti
était prêt évasif je suis pas plus alors
maintenant je veux bien mais allons bien
bon finalement j'en fais deux non en
fait deux
on va faire deux jeux et c'est prêt
ouais mais qu'est ce que je dois faire
tu dois fermer ta gueule vas-y
on le les d'hérault sport onéreux mais
là les poches
voilà les attentions deuxième manche aux
débutants et martin 2e au saut joue pour
deux ados deuxième manche deuxièmement a
choisi a tout fait partie mathieu tu
démarres ouais je démarre aux olonnes il
est là tu avais rien contre
[Rires]
aux mots tricheur
c'est ce qu'a fait un an sont sortis
qualité se retrouve à tuer des cas c'est
le cas par cas c'est matthieu pita mais
j'en ai marre et eric de tunisiens
sérieux casse et c'est clair c'est
attention s'est pas fait à l'e3 des
mégalithes et on s'embrasse sur la
bouche
ouais remettant à 2,3 non seulement de
grands bras ces personnes sur la bouche
et on pousse tous sauf s'il va prendre
quelques salles à ces parias l'outaouais
n'a été trouvée là c'est rien du tout
arriver là mais c'est marrant toi c'est
parti albert pas sur visage sur les eaux
des salles dernier le village on mettra
des lunettes et moi je suis là non
quant aux attentes en raison mais on
adore aller va n'y a pas de s'être tu
jouis ça ne rien coûter moi confiance
surtout je le fais mais tu m'as vu tu as
ton spectacle mais c'est des trucs tu
m'as pas salir tu m'as fait peur j'ai
cru que c'était mais des trucs pour le
gardien c'est pour pertes et regarde à
monsieur guy boucher horrible regarde
céréales et rien ne sait rien du tout ça
ah non pas du tout ça sous le sapin
moi comme je lé fais si je rejoue pas
c'est ça le seul à les écrase pas alors
tu as raison mon sac tous ces partis
mais leur curé fils c'est là dernier
c'est pour le ca pour les âges de
vitesse pour les vitesses
attention à deux on la fait tous en même
temps 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je suis content alors
tarasy mes toiles à rallonge temps
arrange toi village que si tu veux je
t'échange ça contre le bisou sur la
bouche et bizet il faut qu'ils soient
d'accord moi vrai bisou sur la bouche il
a pas ça ouais
s'il veut pas diminuer sur la bouche il
prend le lâchait jamais tenu bon et a
joué aussi j'ai joué à droite décider
parce que c'est déjà ça c'est pas mal
déjà il en reste un petit peu à temps
voilà laisse les siens
c'est magnifique vous êtes prêts tu vas
toi parce qu'elle me dit que ça
dégouline on dirait que fait pipi
non non non non c'est bon dit rien du
tout pour l'instant mais il ya
l'histoire
vas-y tu faisais tmb hockey
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est rien c'est rien c'est du coude
c'est rien c'est que des bonnes choses
c'est que des bonnes choses
récemment la série de noms sur l'aérien
à léo barbé écoute ça va si tu t'es pris
en 50 me suis monsieur poulpe